hey I'm Sharia Jalil I live
Ontario Canada I have been in I.T sector
for the past 20 years I recently took
the professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my career and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band
thank you